[Musique]
et jean pierre farandou qui s'installe
donc en direct merci beaucoup jean
pierre farandou d'être notre invité ce
matin vous êtes le pdg de la sncf merci
d'être avec nous pendant un peu plus de
vingt minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par patrice moyon de ouest
france bonjour patrice bonjour oriane
jean pierre farandou on va parler
évidemment de votre projet faire contre
carbonne un projet évidemment qui dans
ses tongs l'écologie a une importance
considérable a évidemment une importance
aussi pour la sncf mais d'abord on va
parler de l'actualité les syndicats de
la sncf ont annoncé une grève pour le 6
juillet prochain pour une augmentation
urgente des salaires pour faire face à
l'inflation à ce que vous reconnaissez
dans le contexte actuel cette
augmentation est nécessaire à la sncf on
essaie de pratiquer un dialogue social
de solutions de discussion et pas trop
d'obstruction et de blocage parce qu'on
pense toujours aux usagers aux passagers
qui veulent prendre le train donc non on
fait tout pour éviter des tensions
sociales trop forte pression le sujet
des salaires oui oui bien sûr les
cheminots c'est comme les salariés
français ils ont subi un problème de
pouvoir d'achat très fort depuis le
début de l'année il ya ans avec la
sortie du coc vide avait entraîné un
mouvement peu d'inflation forte parce
que l'économie était en surchauffe et se
rajoute la crise la crise ukrainienne
qui a fait monter le coût de l'énergie
le coût des matières premières le coût
de l'alimentation donc il y aura une
augmentation des salaires ouais il y
aura quelque chose on en discute on en
discute d'ailleurs depuis déjà plusieurs
semaines j'en ai entendu qu aurait pas
de discussion les cfc c'est pas vrai du
tout moi même d'ailleurs je suis
impliqué dans ces réunions j'ai vu
personnellement les quatre organisations
syndicales représentatives on habille
les sujets sur la table on essaie de
construire un équilibre parce que
augmenter les salaires c'est une chose
mais aussi un enjeu économique un ça
coûte il faut faire attention que
de la répercussion sur le prix des
billets par exemple augmentent augmenter
les salaires c'est bien mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire matière de coûts pour
faire aussi attention en gir de l'isère
au public à la sncf n'en font qu'à la
fin de l'année l'entreprise reste
équilibré pour pas qu'on coûte au pays
voilà donc le rôle d'un dirigeant c'est
compliqué il faut satisfaire des
revendications sociales légitimes et à
la fois conserver les grands équilibres
du spectre est elle hésite juste une
question oui justement en france il ya
143 branche sur 171 qui démarre en
dessous du smic et est-ce qu'à la sncf
il ya des
débris qui démarque en dessous du smic
ou qui s'en rapproche non on est on est
on est encore au dessus du smig
heureusement mais c'est vrai que le smic
à remonter donc le smic s'est rapproché
nos minima sur un sujet d'ailleurs qui
est sur la table voire risque ya pas
lieu de remonter les plus bas salaires
de la sncf on voit bien que on parlait
de pouvoir d'achat ce qui en souffre le
plus ce sont les plus bas salaires bien
évidemment donc il ya certainement dans
les discussions que nous avons eues les
syndicats un effort envisager plus
orienté vers les bas salaires et en
particulier ceux qui démarrent ce qu'ils
sont des bulles grille salariale à la
sncf mais cette augmentation des
salaires elle fera générale pour faire
face à l'inflation alors ça fait partie
des discussions quelles modalités il ya
plein modalités pour augmenter les
salaires donc voilà je n'en dis pas plus
à ce stade c'est vraiment des trous non
confirmées qui aura une discussion les 6
juillet
et j'espère qu'elle sera conclusive est
con on arrivera à se mettre d'accord sur
des mesures d'urgence c7 c'est une
clause de revoyure en quelque sorte je
rappelle qu'on a des négociations
annuelles obligatoires les ccef comme
toutes les entreprises qui rythment ces
discussions sur les la structure des
salaires le niveau des salaires on en a
fait une fin 2021 on a d'ailleurs
beaucoup travaillé sur la grille et la
grille pour l'été on a deux types
d'agents les cfd statutaire qui sont
encore aux statuts puis ce qu'on recrute
en droit travail normal donc on a
décoincé la grille c'est ce qu'on ait le
vocabulaire qu'on utilise parce que on
avait des gens qui étaient en bout en
butée de grille on a beaucoup travaillé
là-dessus on va travailler sur les bas
salaires aussi fun fun 2021 en 2023 on
se reverra pour la nouvelle négociation
annuelle obligatoire là il ya besoin de
se voir pour traiter en urgence
effectivement ces sujets chauds à 2 de
pouvoir d'achat parce que on est
parfaitement conscient que oui les
cheminots et notamment les plus bas
salaires ont des difficultés compte tenu
du renchérissement du coût de la vie
pour être calé sur l'augmentation du
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires qui va
être annoncée par un gouvernement quel
est peut-être pas parce qu'il n'y a pas
de raison on a par exemple ou des
mécanismes justement de statutaire qui
font que il ya des mécanismes
automatiques d'un lancement automatique
dans notre système que clés qui sont
peut-être plus généreux à la sncf qui ne
son côté l'état mais c'est un élément
important où on verra bien sur l'effort
qui sera fait par l'état pour les
fonctionnaires vous avez un volant
d'heures sur cette augmentation ou c'est
trop tôt prononcer trop tôt pour le dire
mais pas de plantation générale des
salaires depuis 2000 14 disent les
syndicats
alors ce qui se passe à la sncf je sais
que rona on a une grille à une grille
statutaires et cette grise à sutter elle
génère des augmentations sont quasiment
semi automatique on a dans notre jargon
des positions de rémunération c'est
comme une grille on a des niveaux en ad
on ad on a dégradé classification des
qualifications et pendant la dizaine
d'années où l'inflation a été très basse
puisque en gros pendant dix ans
l'inflation était autour de 1% ces
mécanismes spécifiques à la grille de la
sncf généré 2 % d'augmentation par an
donc au fond ces mécanismes là ont
largement couvert l'inflation pendant
dix ans l'élément nouveau c'est ce qui
se passe maintenant c'est qu'on n'est
pas 2 % on n'est pas important n'est pas
2% mais a plus voilà donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut une discussion sur le
complément ajouté par rapport à ces
mécanismes statutaire de la grille de la
sncf train dernier mot là dessus puisque
évidemment sa nouvelle tombe au début
des vacances pour beaucoup de français
une inquiétude est ce que cette grève va
durer est-ce que vous pouvez rassurer
les français là dessus est-ce qu'elle
sera une grève le 6 juillet où est-ce
qu'elle pourrait être amenée à durer ce
qui pourrait y avoir d'autres grèves
pendant l'été quand on regarde le
préavis a été déposé par les syndicats
cgt une journée du seule journée ce
qu'on appelle une crête 2 et 4 heures
une gaffe car aidant vocabulaire bon
voilà on peut être qu'elle n'aura pas
lieu cette grève on va discuter pour
essayer d'éviter peut-être qu'elle aura
lieu sellal yeux ça durera qu'une
journée et dont les grands départs qui
filles ne sont pas menacées c'est
important parce que là aussi j'ai eu moi
je crois qu'on voit aussi le sens des
responsabilités les syndicats je pense
qu'elle syndicale sncf les cheminots ils
veulent pas prendre en otage les grands
départs ils veulent manifester
l'importance pour eux de ce sujet
pouvoir d'achat c'est la modalité qu'ils
ont choisi mais on peut rassurer les
français pour les grands départs pendant
toutes les vacances je pense qu'il aura
pas de problèmes sociaux à l'essai mais
vous voyez discuter avant pour qu'un
espagnol pour caen même si je discute on
est en train de discuter moi j'ai
toujours l'espoir que les discussions
permettent peut-être de déboucher avant
l'avant le 6 juillet justement les
français il aime le train et le montre
puisque les trains sont très basses eaux
pour cette période de vacances est ce
que tous ceux qui le souhaitent pourront
partir en vacances en transe att alors
d'aborder on est ravi de voir que les
français choisissent le train c'est une
très très bonne nouvelle vous savez
qu'on vient de passer deux semblent
compliquées après le coup vide on a
besoin de sentir que les français aiment
le train c'est le cas il se déplace en
france ils choisissent le train on a
vendu 10 % de places de plus que qu'à la
même époque en 2010 9,1 16h30 19 qui est
la vraie année de référence pour nous
puisque 20 et 21 c était d adecco vite
donc on est ravi de voir les franchises
choisissent le train et c'est très bien
d'ailleurs c'est très bon pour la
planète aussi on y reviendra demain et
on est ravis on fait rouler tout notre
atout nos tgv roule en double et en
double les tgv pour offrir plus de
capacité on a réussi d'ailleurs et c'est
un petit exploit à offrir 500 milles de
places supplémentaires là encore quand
on se compare par rapport à 2019 dont
vraiment on est au maximum et comme
jeudi les cheminots qui vont travailler
par pour assurer les les
des vacances des français alors après si
vous voulez voyager la veille du 14
juillet au moment où on est vraiment des
samis et grands départs je pense que là
elle est élue et sans dire très plein
donc il ya encore de la place il faut
accepter se déplacer d'un jour deux
jours hélas rassurez vous il ya encore
de la place dont les français qui
veulent voyager en train cet été peuvent
le faire en acceptant certainement ne
pas être sur les jours de très très
grands départs et de décaler de quelques
jours lors dates de départ et de retour
vraiment puisqu'on parlait de la crise
du cabinet ce que vous arrivez à
chiffrer combien la crise du cabinda a
coûté à la sncf par la crise du coc vie
dans leur appel à ça a été violent
puisque pour des mieux pour des raisons
sanitaires que bien sûr on a respecté
avec beaucoup de discipline la mobilité
s'est arrêté en mars 2020 le quasiment
aucun tgv ne roule et ne roulait plus on
avait pour assurer une service public
minimum un tgv par jour sur lui en sont
là c'est sûr bordeaux etc mais et ces
déchets étaient quasiment vides puisque
les français n'avaient pas le droit de
voyager sur plusieurs régions on s'en
souvient voilà l'impact il est terrible
forcément et puis de recettes sur les
tgv on estime que les pertes sur deux
ans en chiffre d'affaires c'est de ça
dépasse 10 milliards d'euros les pères
sur chiffre d'affaires alors on a réussi
à limiter ses pertes en faisant des
économies on a fait un plan d'économie
drastique pour récupérer au maximum de
ses paires de recettes on a à peu près
divisé par deux l'impact les bacs des
recettes en faisant des économies donc
en gros l'impact net il est autour de 5
milliards voilà donc c'est quand même un
coup un coût important il a fallu
l'encaissé et surtout se préparer à
rebondir et c'est ce qu'on a fait avec
succès quand on voit ce qui se passe cet
été alors aujourd'hui les prix de
l'énergie s'envolent qu'est l'impact de
l'envolée ces prix d'énergie sur le prix
des billets pour les voyageurs alors
c'est vrai le pré l'énergie s'envolent
on le voit toute l'énergie l'électricité
le gaz oil tout le monde et nous la sncf
on est un gros consommateur d'énergie en
particulier l'électricité voilà je crois
d'ailleurs qu'on est le premier client
ddf donc on est un cours très gros
consommateurs d'électricité en matière
de prix nos acheteurs avaient bien
travaillé puisque il ya quelques années
il avait passé des contrats pluriannuels
donc on avait convenu à l'avance du prix
d'achat de l'électricité pour 2022 dont
là dessus on est couvert et donc cette
année on va pas trop souffrir
l'augmentation des prix donc il y aura
pas de répercussion sur le prix des
billets cette année je les dis et
d'ailleurs c'est conforme puisqu'on veut
encourager l'utilisation du train on va
aimer qu'on essayait de maintenir des
prix les plus raisonnables possibles
pour que tous les français puissent
accéder aux trains l'année prochaine là
on est moins bien couverts par ces
achats anticipés donc il y aura donc
pour nour mentation la facture énergie
c'est un milliard d'euros à peu près
rien bon voilà donc sur un milliard
d'euros ben vous voyez à 10% ces 100
millions 20 % ses 200 millions ça va
vite là il n'a pas encore décidé mais on
sera peut-être obligé de répercuter sur
le prix des billets parce que si les
coûts augmentent les coûts d'électricité
peut-être les coûts des salaires on en
parlait aussi les coûts des matières
premières le coût de la cie pour les
travaux etc etc on sera peut-être obligé
d'augmenter les prix de l'édition n'est
pas encore plus en 2023 en 2023 voilà
donc en 2022 on ne manque pas en 2023 on
s'interroge on va regarder d'ici la fin
d'année comment nous coup évolué et
justement va parler des collégiens les
d'énergie puisque les fournisseurs
d'énergie en blanc dès dimanche de
réduire la consommation d'énergie est ce
que vous vous redoutez des restrictions
cet hiver des restrictions d'énergie et
comment vous allez réduire votre
consommation
moi je voulais commencer à dire d'abord
que prendre le train c'est déjà réduire
sa consommation d'énergie sa
consommation d'énergie par don puisque
quelques chiffres aux passagers
transportés le train qu'on semble
dix fois moins d'énergie que la route
que l'avion donc c'est énorme yahya
yahya le sujet de l'émission des gaz à
effet de serre mais aussi l'énergie le
camion c'est six fois moins pourquoi
parce que le train une fois qu'il est
que sa masse est émise en mouvement il
frotte pas une roue en faire sur rail en
faire il ya zéro frottement donc zéro
consommation d'énergie vous avez qu'un
tgv par exemple qui arrive de marseille
si vous coupez les moteurs ou du morvan
vous arrivez tout seul la gare de lyon
voilà parce que sur son propre mouvement
appelle ça roulait sur l'air vous n'avez
pas besoin de consommer l'énergie dans
déjà choisir le train c'est consommer
beaucoup moins d'énergie deuxièmement on
demande à nos conducteurs qui sont des
grands professionnels ils savent ajuster
leur conduite pour consommer le moins
d'énergie possible on appelle ça l'éco
conduite ça peut aller jusqu'à 10%
économies de consommation électricité en
fait il faut anticiper sur le relief
beaucoup à ses 7 juillet pour le moment
il ne faut pas il faut pas freiner
inutilement faut anticiper sur le relief
du twr le 2-2 de la ligne et on arrive à
des économies importantes voilà donc
après en terme de frugalité bien sûr ce
tome frugalité est important le fait
dans les bureaux on va jouer sur ben un
peu moins de climatisation pour pour
s'être pour cet été et moi même
d'ailleurs j'ai pu de climatisation on
est un peu chaud on baisse les volets
c'est pas très grave cet hiver ce sera
pareil je pense qu'on mettra des pubs
pour venir travailler est ce que c'est
si grave que ça enfin moi je suis
complètement solidaires de cet effort de
cilic au fond qui nous est demandé
non seulement par les producteurs
d'énergie mais par le pays par la
solidarité nationale on en connaît le
contexte avec cette guerre en ukraine
qui pose des problèmes
d'approvisionnement d'énergie il faut
que les français nous soyons solidaires
pour résister au mieux à ces tensions
sur l'énergie d'alors lui le train le
train et portant aujourd'hui dans le
contexte du changement climatique vous
ambitionnez de doubler le nombre de
passagers transportés vous allez faire
comment dans ces conditions alors à
commencer par pourquoi après enfin le
commencer important le pourquoi parce
qu'il faut que ça vous allez voir
abandonnée on va demander de
l'investissement en argent public donc
faut que le pourquoi c'est très fort
donc l'intérêt général soit établie
sinon on n'est pas légitime alors
premièrement pour effectivement réduire
drastiquement les émissions de gas et de
casse à effet de serre le tgv c'est
cinquante fois moins d'émissions que la
voiture 80 fois moins que l'avion c'est
considérable donc si on veut un effet
sur les sur le sur les sur les
réductions de co2 et gaz à effet de
serre il faut un report en report modal
le jargon c'est un report de la route
vers le train pour les voyageurs et pour
les marchandises deuxièmement moi j'ai
une ambition pour les territoires je
pense que le train peut aider notamment
à la desserte autour des grandes villes
et en région et idées et et désenclaver
les villes moyennes et non seulement les
villes moyennes mais les territoires
ruraux voilà donc il ya le train de
l'épiné dorsale d'une mobilité douce
d'une mobilité collective qui peut
offrir une vraie alternative à la
voiture c'est bon pour le pouvoir
d'achat parce que les abonnements qu'on
pourra proposer avec les régions sur ses
trains la coûteront beaucoup moins cher
que l'usagé la voiture et c'est bon pour
l'emploi parce que c'est trop lance
industriels sur le ferroviaire à la fois
les lignes comme le matériel roulant la
signalisation peut aller jusqu'à 100000
emplois créés dans le pays voilà dans
les enjeux sont considérables alors
comment on fait il faut travailler sur
le réseau aujourd'hui le réseau
ferroviaire français il est saturé il
arrive qu'ils pourraient pas transporter
davantage donc les vieillissants il vit
sans est saturé et il est en train de
passer à côté aussi de so2 sont
énergiques comme moi développer en
europe comme ce qu'on appelle et et
comment centralisée des grandes poser du
viage à grand rayon d'action les
allemands le fond les suisses le fond
les belges le fond les italiens pour le
faire vous n'êtes là on est en train de
prendre du retard voilà nous faut mais
de l'argent sur le réseau c'est un bon
investissement ça permettra d'avoir de
la fiabilité la capacité ça permettra
d'avoir de la réactivité et ça permettra
de développer des nouveaux services moi
j'en vois trois ce que donc ce service
de réseau express métropolitains des rer
autour des grandes villes comme bordeaux
lyon nantes lille strasbourg et c'est
pour offrir une alternative à des gens
qui habitent avec 30 kilos mais des
centres villes quand vous rajoutez les
uns des feux qui arrivent des zones a
fait la nation comment on va faire il
faut vraiment il ya que le train pour
pour de prouver une offre alternative
avec des étoiles ferroviaire vous savez
ces branches de lignes qui desservent le
coeur des villes pour ça c'est très bon
pour j'ai pas une dizaine de millions de
français pourraient en profiter puisque
on a treize projets qui sont prêts bref
vous chiffré à combien vous
- en termes de nos besoins ils sont à
peu près comparable à ce que font les
autres grands pays qu'ils ont décidé
nous il faut encore le décider il ya les
allemands vous remettre 85 milliard
d'euros pour en dix ans pour rénover le
réseau et les italiens vont mettre 130
milliards d'euros voilà les besoins en
france on hume est mort voilà autour de
la centaine de milliards est vrai la
vision que j'ai c'est que finalement le
ferroviaire a déjà changé la france
était le tgvt je vais transformer la
france et 100 milliards le tgv mais moi
je dis il faut 100 milliards pour
transformer la france mais pas que pour
la grande vitesse pour les transports de
la vie quotidienne et pour le fret avec
une vision très large du bénéfice pour
les français est-ce que ce projet faire
contre carbone c'est aussi une réponse à
jean et jean pierre on doit ce sentiment
d'abandon de certains français oui oui
je je je pense que les gilet jaune ils
ont réagi quand on quand il ya eu l'idée
d'une taxe qui allait alourdir leur
cours le le le le coût des carburants
puis ça a été la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase quoi c'est les gens
c'est compliqué il habite loin des
centres villes ils ont déjà le poids une
congestion routière il n'a pas trop
garer leur voiture et en plus on est le
carburant dont le prix est allé à les
augmenter donc voilà c'est bon en fait
ils demanderaient pas mieux que de
laisser leur voiture au garage le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui a pas
d'alternative moi je pense qu'en
travaillant dans les territoires on peut
trouver effectivement une solution
alternative à l'ems cc je vous dis c'est
la capitale la capitale régionale comme
bordeaux qui est très avancé d'ailleurs
sur le réseau express mais mais mais
metropolit et à bordeaux ensuite vous
avez les villes moyennes comme libourne
war cachons qui saura à 30 km 40 km de
bordeaux là vous faites des dessertes
fréquentent tous les quarts d'heure en
période de pointe et ensuite faut pas
s'arrêter là il faut offrir au village
au bourg qui sont pas très loin libre ne
pas trop hein d'un d'arcachon des
systèmes de transport à la demande des
système de ramassage des systèmes de
taxis collectifs des systèmes aussi à
tout simplement avec un parking des
parkings autour des gares où vous partez
de chez vous ou en voiture et au lieu
d'aller jusqu'au centre de la grande
ville vous arrêtez la première gare
utile et là vous allez prendre le train
voilà si on met vous travaillez aussi à
des nouveaux trains pourra améliorer
justement la desserte dans ces
territoires oui alors en plus on est
très innovant sncf on a on a une train
d'inventer des nouveaux modes de
transports par exemple au delà des
engins rail route qui peuvent devenir en
train mais qui peuvent devenir une
voiture pour aller dans un hameau qui
est pas raccordés au très vous êtes une
voiture ou charger 10 15 ou 20 personnes
vous vous rapprochez par la revue voie
ferrée vous montez sur les voies ferrées
vous devenez un train il vous fait un
parcours en train voilà et s'il faut
vous pouvez ressortir d'ailleurs pour à
nouveau faire une desserte fine donc on
est en train de monter de monter ces
angles-là s'appelle flexi c'est la
combinaison du monde routier du monde
ferroviaire alors juste une petite
précision parce que la sncf est déjà
lourdement endettée est ce que là est ce
que la remontée des taux va fragiliser
vos investissements sur le plan
économique alors sur la dette en se
soignant alors c'est tout l'esprit delà
de la réforme 2018 kiki qui est qui et
vous allez leur fantaisie sur leur appel
au plan économique c'est l'état reprend
35 milliards d'euros de dette des snf
réseau qui c'était en été pour faire le
tgv on sait d'où ça vient elle profite
les lignes à grande vitesse dans l'est
et en contrepartie l'état nous demande à
nous les le management est à moi le
président de 2,2 du groupe d'avoir un
programme de rigueur et de retour à
l'équipe pour justement ne plus se
serait endetté est on en train de le
faire malgré deux qu'ovide danse est une
vraie performance et séjours odyssée d
or au public quand on fait ça on en
vient peu allégés ou en deviennent ne
pas demander de l'argent public
supplémentaire bon on est en chemin et
là je rejoins discutait pas plus tard
qu'hier avec mon directeur financier il
disait qu on revient à des ratios tout à
fait correct entre la dette et on
appelle ça libye dallas la marge
d'exploitation on est dans des rapports
de 2 à 4 donc on ne vienne entreprises
équilibré si vous voulez on est on est
plus sûr en été on en a on a un niveau
élevé de dette mais qui devient
raisonnable qu'ils achètent ou alors
remontée des taux
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle bien
évidemment là encore on est très prudent
on avait on a contacté beaucoup de
beaucoup d'emprunts avec des taux longs
et les taux fixes est relativement bas
donc bien sûr on aura une exposition à
la remontée des taux mais là encore la
manière dont on a structuré une autre
date est trouvée notion de financement
va nous protéger de la remontée des taux
pourrait revenir sur sa maillage
territorial sur lequel vous travaillez
auquel vous tenez vous devez forcément
travailler avec les élus locaux comment
ça c'est ce qu'ils sont prêts à investir
sur le temps les élus locaux surtout
dans le contexte actuel moi je rencontre
de plus en plus les locaux qui inquiète
ont compris que le train est la solution
tout cas une vraie solution une vraie
alternative au tout voiture tout voiture
congestion pollution coup il faut du
train là encore prenant l'exemple de
bordeaux puis pour moi qui est l'exemple
le plus en pointe bon on a la chance à
bordeaux d'avoir un président de région
alain rousset qui qui est aligné avec le
président de la métropole alain anziani
et qui ont décidé tous les deux parce
qu'ils vont travailler ensemble et faut
que la région est la métropole
travaillent ensemble justement d'avancé
sur ce projet de réseau express
métropolitains moi je les soutiens
beaucoup
je veux absolument que ce projet avance
et il avance et j'essaierai d'ailleurs
de voir comment on peut accélérer encore
la l'avancée de ce projet parce que
c'est la vitrine de ce qu'on peut faire
voilà c'est vraiment la vitrine de la
réponse qu'on peut apporter à ces
territoires donc oui les à la fois les
régions mais aussi des présidents
métropole sont prêts à avancer j'en
discutais aussi avec
bruno bruno bernard qui est le président
de l'as de la métropole de lyon c'est
pareil dans les mêmes dispositions
d'esprit on a des présidents ou michaël
delafosse à
à montpellier on a des élus qui ont
compris que des élus métropole qui ont
compris qu'il fallait qu'ils s'occupent
de la mobilité des gens qui n'habitent
pas la métropole mais qui viennent tous
les jours ou pour travailler ou pour les
loisirs ou pour aller à l'hôpital pour
profiter des services donc on a un
aliment des planètes on a unanimement de
la volonté politique il faut savoir la
saisir et j'espère que l'état aussi bien
à aider ces élus locaux à avancer dans
ses projets de transport ferroviaire des
élus qui sont contents vous avez sans
doute entendu xavier bertrand le
président de la région des hauts de
france jeudi qu'il a dit qu'il ne
reprendrait pas ses paiements à la sncf
pour protester contre les défaillances
du réseau ter ils dénoncent les
suppressions de trains et dit j'en ai
marre de me faire enfumer qu'est ce que
vous lui dites ont d'abord juste deux
choses fait moi je moi je pense d'abord
aux usagers et là dessus il a raison en
ce moment la sncf pour des raisons 1 un
peu structuré de ressources de réseau de
congestion des réseaux de manque d'eau
conduites heures parce que les les
écoles de conduite de formation des
conducteurs se sont arrêtés pendant la
crise qu vider sa part et est elle
suffisamment anticipé donc on a des
problèmes de production du service et
c'est vrai dans son mécontentement il
est logique et il ne fait que re lille
mécontents des usagers on pense à eux là
dessus on a un plan d'action on se
mobilise à fond pour rattraper rattraper
ce retard ça va prendre quelques mois
parce que on peut pas du jour au
lendemain être fabriqué des conducteurs
en année navré parce que c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment la qualité de service n
est pas bonne dont je comprends sa
colère il est bon le comprenez qu'il
suspende le paiement un peu moins parce
que moi je paye moi je paye tous les
mois les cheminots moi je paye tout
l'électricité je paye des fournisseurs
je paye la maintenance
on est une entreprise publique certes
mais mais quand même on est soucieux d
euros d euros des français quand on paie
pas les ccef on ne paie pas la
collectivité au fond donc
je comprends la mauvaise humeur je
comprends son sens google je comprends
tout à fait je comprends qu'ils mènent
la pression en quelque sorte mais la
modalité qui vaut 6 à pas nous payer
elle peut elle doit discuter sachant
qu'il n'est pas l'écrit la région grand
est aussi vous allez discuter avec lui
ne trouve pas allé le rencontrer
prochainement je discute avec lui je
suis en contact avec lui le contact
n'est pas rompu bien évidemment et c'est
important
voilà il ya deux ans d'action le premier
le principal c'est la production de la
qualité la production dire moi même je
suis allé deux fois pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière à 6 heures du matin
j'étais arrières damien donc j'étais à
porter baffe comme dirait le président
bertrand d'ailleurs
oui ou gérard larcher j'ai vu un très
supris mais j'ai vu un très en retard
j'ai eu usage et qui était pas content
voilà et quelle que ce jour avant
semaine à manger tel à saint-quentin
pareil donc je vais sur le terrain pour
rencontrer aller au contact des usagers
voir les cheminots aussi qu'ils font de
leur mieux il faut pas accabler les
cheminots il forme tourner au mieux pour
propos pour que ça tourne on a des
conditions difficiles pour revenir à ce
maillage territorial qui vous est cher
il ya l'ouverture à la concurrence est
ce que cette ouverture à la concurrence
plus menacé à moyen terme ce maillage
territorial
alors l'ouverture à la concurrence peut
être faire expliquer comment ça marche
il ya deux manières d'ouvrir la
concurrence il ya le un peu comme dans
l'aérien on a les italiens on a un
concurrent dans la grande licence sont
les italiens de trading qui font qu'ils
opèrent des trains entre bilans turin
chambéry lyon et paris alors qu'il vit
c'est lyon paris ils se trompent pas il
attaque la ligne la plus rentable de la
sncf 1 voilà donc il y en a pas beaucoup
il y avait deux allers-retours malaria
l'a51 nous on a une vingtaine de trains
d'un côté donc voilà il n'ya pas mort
d'homme mais on s'en sort pas trop mal
et l'autre mode de concurrence alors
qu'ils harmonisent beaucoup plus active
c'est la concurrence pour les trains
régionaux voilà plusieurs régions on a
parlé d'autres france grant est il le
france mont louis lefranc aussi ouvrir
la concurrence donc la laddh et des lots
entiers de deux traits régionaux pour la
concurrence est plus facile parce que
dans le régional parce que le matériel
roulant est fournie par les régions et
les conducteurs on est obligé de les
transférer chez le concurrent voilà deux
n'y a pas de barrière d'entrée alors que
sur le tgv c'est plus compliqué il faut
que le concurrent achète ses tgv prenne
ce risque etc voilà les deux modalités
alors la concurrence langlement de la
concurrence a peut être plutôt sur les
tgv puisque à partir de membres il nous
est crème seline rentable est-ce que
l'on va continuer à les souligner pas
rentable ça on le faisait avant il y
avait une péréquation et la péréquation
ccc ccc
c'est un concept qui est qui et qui
connut de la république française et les
entreprises publiques on le faisait donc
comment gagner de l'argent sur les
lignes rentables en accepter au fond et
avec plaisir au fond parce que c'est
notre adn de desservir le territoire de
continuer d'aller sur les situations pas
rentable si on écrémé sur les unes
rentable là ça peut poser problème et
orci a pas trop de concurrence ça va
aller ça l'à beaucoup on sera obligé
d'aller voir les terres en disant qu est
ce qu on fait quoi il faut que vous nous
aidiez à continuer la desserte des
lignes pas rentable parce que je suis
sûr que les concurrents ils vont pas
aller sur l'île pas rentable donc ça
sera soit l'état de remettre la main à
la poche soit ces lignes non rentables
seront supprimés et qui desservent des
territoires qui sont justement ceux
souvent oubliée exactement un an plus
tôt justement puisqu'on parle de l'état
jean castex le premier ministre l'ancien
premier ministre était très attaché au
ferroviaire il a d'ailleurs
c'est les petites lignes la relance et
les trains de nuit est ce que là le
changement de premier ministre et la
crise politique qui s'annonce vous
inquiète sur les investissements de
l'état sur le ferroviaire - écoutez moi
et moi j'ai d'abord joué rendre hommage
à jean castex comme vous franchement on
peut dire qu'on a eu la chance de cette
chance était justifiée et d'un prémisse
qui avait compris je demande tout ce que
le train pouvait amener à l'économie de
la france et à l'aménagement du
territoire en france à la fois les pour
les marchandises a relancé le train des
primeurs entre perpignan et agen jce et
pour les voyageurs avec une approche
très volontariste et une capacité de
passer des accords avec les régions pour
la relance des petites lignes qu'on
appelle les lignes de desserte fine du
territoire voilà que jargon on peut un
peu technocratique donc ensuite moi moi
quand j'ai vu le l'ossature de ce
gouvernement moi je suis ravi un
ministère dela de la transition
écologique la planification écologique
la cohésion des territoires c'est tout à
fait le projet que je porte
dont moi je savais qu'avec ce ministre
ou sept ministres je pense que je suis
en capacité d'apporter le volet
ferroviaire en fait à la planification
écologique au service des territoires
donc voilà on ne pourra pas miser
transport dédiés comme dans le précédent
gouvernement
c'est à dire le plus important c'est
vraiment qu'on travaille pour de vrai
sur la planification écologique et la
cohésion des territoires ensuite on nous
a annoncé quand même qu'ils auraient un
secrétaire d'état aux transports bresse
que je pense que ce les volets
techniques le ou la ministre de la
planification aura besoin de relais
techniques pour s'occuper des transports
et dernière question sur le crâne patron
justement on a vu avec avec l'ukraine
l'importance du 2d du réseau ferroviaire
un pur et qui reste essentielle quelle
quelle réflexion est ce que ça vous
inspire aujourd'hui pour la france ah
bon on va rendre hommage aux cheminots
craignait il sera admirable il continue
à conduire les trains de marchandises et
de voyageurs sous les bombes
voilà ce qui mérite notre hommage de
collègues de cheminon un cheminot
chapeau les cheminots ukrainien pour ce
qu'ils font pour leur pays pour les gens
qui vivent dans leur pays à travers ça
aussi on ma conviction c'est que le
ferroviaire il est adapté à la france et
à l'europe c'est le mode de transport
par excellence pour ce continent où les
distances sont pas trop longue où il ya
beaucoup de granville eux pas si
éloignées les unes des autres où on a
des dix ans aussi pour les marchandises
qui reste raisonnable en centaines en
centaines de kilomètres le ferroviaire a
construit la france et l'europe je pense
que le ferroviaire aussi c'est l'avenir
de la mobilité pour la france et
l'europe voilà ils structurent le
territoire c'est une espèce de colonne
vertébrale autour duquel la vie
s'organise et le projet que je propose
fois 2-1 deux fois plus de voyageurs de
voix plus de train c'est ouvrir cette
perspective d'un ferroviaire qui se met
au service de tous les français qu'ils
habitent dans les grandes villes comme
dans les zones rurales et qui se met au
service des entreprises pour que leur
acheminement soit plus vers puisqu'on
sait que les entreprises cherchent aussi
des modes de transport pour leurs
produits qu'ils soient plus protecteur
de la planète merci jean pierre farandou
merci beaucoup d'avoir était notre
invité ce matin on regarde la une de
ouest france puisqu'on parlait de
l'ukraine dans le crâne en guerre
enquête sur une exécution c'est à la une
de ouest france merci jean pierre
farandou d'avoir été avec nous on passe
au club d'états
[Musique]